بينما كان
يصحف بقواته ومقاتله نحو موسكو كانت جبهه
القتال في اوكرانيا تعيش على وقع تحولات
متسارعه بشان القوات الاوكرانيه هجمات
المتزامنه على الجبهه الشرقيه وسط حديث
رسميا اوكراني عن احراز تقدم خصوصا شمال
وجنوب غرب باخموت وخوضها قتالا عنيفا على
طول جبهه زابولوجيا في التفاصيل تحدثت
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني عن هجوم
متزامن في ست بلدات شمال وجنوب باخموت
ابرزها
وبالقرب
منفك جنوب غربي بخموت ترد الدفاع الروسيه
بصد الهجمات الاوكرانيه بالقرب من
فاسليفكا وتقع 20 كيلومترا شمل شرق باخموت
وتصف بالفاشله عمليه هجوميه اوكرانيه في
اتجاهات جنوب
فالقوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه وصلت ايضا
هجمات بريه محدوده على طول جبهه
بينما قالت الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها صدت
هجمات اوكرانيه هناك وقرب بيرفومايسكي
ومارينكا لكن اكبر ما حققه الاوكرانيون
وفق قياده منطقه عمليات جنوب الشرق
اوكرانيا استعاده مواقع باتجاه مدينه لم
تعد تحت سيطرتهم منذ 2014 وتقع قرب كريسنو
جريفكا وتبعد نحو 12 كيلومترا عن دونيتسك
قائد عمليه منطقه الشرق اوكرانيا اتحدث
ايضا عن تنفيذ ما وصفها بالهجمات المدفعيه
الممتازه في اتجاه مقاطعه لوغانسك وهي
جبهه اخرى لم تكن بنفس ذروه وتحرك المشهد
كحل دنيتك
اذا على جبهه وتحديدا ضخمه
وحتى لوغانسك ملامح وضع يريد الاوكرانيون
فرضه في سياق ما يسمونه الهجوم المضاد وسط
تساؤلات عن تاثير ما حدث من تطورات في
روسيا فاذا كان
ومقاتل فاجنر الفضل في السيطره الكامله
على مدينه سوليدار الاستراتيجيه في مقاطعه
الشرقيه اوكرانيا ولاحقا على بخموت فان
غياب هذه القوات او جزء منها يطرح اكثر من
تساؤل اقر رئيس مجموعه فاغنر المسلحه
بان حوالي عشره الاف من بين خمسين الف
سجين جندتهم فاجنر من السجون الروسيه
قتلوا على خط المواجهه في معركه بخموت
الداميه ونسبه مماثله من مقاتله محترفين
لقوا حتفهم ايضا في القتال ووفق الانباء
القادمه من روسيا فانه سيتم عرض عقود
عسكريه منتظمه على الضباط فاجنر الذين لم
يشاركوا في التمرد وسيتم من شاركوا فيه من
القتال واذا تم حل فاغنر فسيؤدي ذلك الى
حرمان روسيا من القوه العسكريه الاكثر
فاعليه في اوكرانيا وفق معهد الدراسات
الحرب
وبحسب المعهد نفسه فان تصرفات اظهرت افقار
روسيا للاحتياطيه في المناطق الخلفيه
والتمرد الذي حدث قد يعطل قدره القوات
الروسيه على الدفاع ضد الهجمات المضاده
الاوكرانيه لكن تحليلا لمعهد ابحاث
السياسه الخارجيه ومقره الولايات المتحده
شكك في ان يكون لتهميش جيش بريكوجين تاثير
كبير لكن موسكو قد تستخدم تمر دافاجنر
لتفسير الخسائر المستقبليه حسب التحليل
[موسيقى]